leurs enfants sont malades ils filent
ukraine pour tenter de les sauver
chez nous il n'y a plus d'endroits pour
prendre en charge les enfants
il n'y a plus de pédiatres il n'ya plus
d'hôpital puisque tout est bombardé mais
moi je voudrais retourner à kharkiv et
je veux que tout ça s'arrête
ces familles embarque pour une ultime
étape vers l'europe la pologne et à 80km
à l'hôpital pour enfants de lviv il ya
les patients de passage et ceux qui trop
affaibli sont pris en charge sur place
du matin au soir dans son bureau le
directeur jongle entre les départs et
les arrivées les enfants malades
affluent de tout le pays
ici et ici il ya des combats là bas
c'est la guerre soigner des enfants est
impossible dans ces zones donc ils sont
transférés vers nous dommage 400 enfants
quinze jours parmi eux oksana et son
fils alexander
bonjour bonjour eux sont arrivés de kiev
il ya quatre jours comment ça va
l'enfant âgé d'un an et atteint d'une
maladie des reins
on va tous sculptés
pour le sauver cette femme n'a eu
d'autre choix que de laisser derrière
elle son mari engagé en ce moment même
dans les combats
il faut fermer le ciel aux avions
nous ne voulons pas que nos enfants
souffrent
ils ne méritent pas ça
toute l'ukraine souffre de cette guerre
dehors au pied de l'hôpital un nouveau
transfert s'organise
on a trois heures de réserve pour
l'oxygène
de cette fois ce sont des ambulances
polonaise qui viennent prêter main forte
si on doit venir
en gilets pare-balles et en convoi il
évacue 240 enfants
dans cet hôpital mille enfants malades
supplémentaires vont arriver dans les
tout prochains jours ils ont besoin en
urgence d'une assistance médicale